Well,
the president should lead,
you know,
you can have individual states and
individual movements,
uh,
deciding,
issues affecting the country.
A president has to set it,
Tom,
and now when it comes to abortion,
I believe that in a woman's right to
choose.
But as president,
I would do everything I can to stop
unwanted pregnancies to,
to push for a adoption and sex education
and family planning.
Uh,
but at the same time,
uh,
when it comes to gay rights,
I think we should be a country that
honors the fact that we shouldn't
discriminate on the basis of race,
gender,
sexual orientation as a Gobbler,
uh,
in our red state,
as I say,
which a conservative state I had fought.
I have fought against those that want to
discriminate against the gays.
And I have got the most gay pro gay
lesbian record in the country.
Not because it's politically popular.
Actually,
it's a very conservative state.
But because it's the right thing to do,
I would try to lead in those areas as
president.
Not imposed my will but,
but take strong moral stands.
Those are value stands.
You know,
we should be a nation of values and
values are not just a religious values.
Other values that we should emphasize is
the right to have healthcare,
the right for a child to be able to go
to school,
the right for anybody to pursue the
American dream.
So I would expand the definition of what
constitutes value.